Hallo, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcasts Ufo. Flot, ihr will es auch da, wir begrüssen euch ganz herzlich. Wir sind angekommen auf unserem neuen Medium Spotify, noch ohne Intro. Sorry, herzlich willkommen auch an Stefan Titsch, wir sind heute neu angekommen. Viele neue Leute werden uns wahrscheinlich entdeckt haben durch dieses Spotify-Prime-Angebot oder auch nicht, man weiss es nicht genau. Wir haben genau, glaube ich, sechs Follower dazu gewonnen, also herzlich willkommen an euch sechs, schön, dass ihr da seid.
Wir können auch mal eine private, so eine Kennenlern-Runde machen, wo sich jemand kurz vorstellt, wo man sich einen Raum sperrt,
wo man irgendwie einen kostenlosen Kaffee mitnimmt, irgendwie so Thermobechern.
Erzählt doch einfach mal ganz kurz was über euch, einfach mal, sagt einfach mal in den Eltern hinaus, schickt uns einfach mal, das wird auch mal schön,
schickt uns einfach mal einen Soundbite, wo ihr euch kurz vorstellt, wo ihr sagt, hallo, ich bin die Claroline, ich spiele gerne die Claranine und es gerne Mandarine und das einfach kurz direkt an zentrale.podcast. Und das noch ein bisschen lustiger, ein bisschen kreativer und dann schickt es einfach mal. Schickt es uns und wir werden den ultimativen Community-Mix zusammenschneiden, damit auch mal die anderen Leute wissen, wer eigentlich noch alles Fans davon sind. Wir haben eine Menge Fragen bekommen, um das einfach mal direkt aus dem Weg zu bekommen,
zum Thema Spotify, die wir alle leider nicht beantworten dürfen.
Und wir dürfen auch leider nicht sagen, dass sie beantworten.
Wir wollen nur ganz kurz eine Sache klar machen, weil da einige Fragen tatsächlich kamen.
Es macht keinen Unterschied, ob ihr uns auf iTunes oder Spotify hört.
Es ist völlig egal. Es ist nicht so, als ob wir per Klick bezahlt werden oder überhaupt bezahlt werden.
Deswegen macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Ihr könnt uns so hören, wie es für euch am besten ist. Bleibt dabei, wie es für euch am besten ist. Denkt daran, dass ihr bei iTunes Bandbreite verliert, pro Monat Datenvolumen verbraucht. Aber nur wenn du bei T-Mobile bist, glaube ich, dann ist Spotify kostenlos. Nee, bei Spotify ist Spotify Datenvolumen. Stimmt, wenn du im Vertrag drin bist, dann verliert ihr kein Datenvolumen. Herzlich willkommen zu diesem Comedy-Podcast. Wir machen Comedy und Bandbreitengags. Viele Bandbreitengags. Wie breit ist deine Bandbreite? Weiss ich nicht. Hilflos, ich habe weit aufgerissene Augen vor mir. Hilfe!
Keine Ahnung. Ja, also ich finde, wir sind angekommen im neuen, wir müssen noch nicht so selbstreferenziert die ganze Zeit darüber reden, aber es waren ein paar wichtige Sachen, wann jetzt anzusprechen. Wir sind auch schon ein bisschen stolz drauf. Ich glaube, man kann das auch sagen, dass wir da durchaus stolz drauf sind, jetzt endlich angekommen zu sein in diesem Medium. Wir gehen aber auch fest davon aus, dass das sowohl mit Urheberrechtsproblemen als auch mit inhaltlichen Problemen, als auch mit dem schwedischen Recht derartig kollidiert, unsere spitzen Zungen, dass wir da sowieso relativ bald wieder runterfliegen. Deswegen freut euch jetzt einfach schon mal, dass ihr Teil dieser Phase gewesen seid, Podcast-Ufo auf Spotify, wenn auch nur kurz. Manchmal wünsche ich mir, weil es kommen ein paar Fragen rein, so auch an unsere Facebook-Page und so, dass wir ein Bot hätten, was uns die Fragen beantwortet. Und das gibt es ja. Also das habe ich noch nie hier erzählt, aber das begleitet mich seit ein paar Monaten wie so ein Geist, der in meinem Kopf lebt, der begleitet mich so ein bisschen, dieses Bewusstsein, dass es ein Bot gibt, was seine Facebook-Page, das ist nicht für Prominente oder so so. Für jeden normalen Menschen, der kann sich dieses Bot, das ist so ein Startup aus Kopenhagen oder so, kann sich so ein Bot holen und das pflegt einfach deine Facebook-Page zum Beispiel. Das heißt, es postet manchmal, es scannt, wie du bisher warst und welchen Abstand du Dinge gepostet hast, teilt ungefähr die gleichen Artikel. Produziert auch neue Folgen und postet die neuen Folgen dann auch automatisch? Ja, teilt ungefähr die gleichen Bilder, lädt Fotos hoch und so, hat einer, so ein Redakteur hat einen Test gemacht, hat jetzt einfach so ein urheberrechtsgeschütztes Bild hochgeladen. Aber es kann halt selber keine Bilder machen, deswegen lädt es halt irgendwie verbotenes Zeug hoch. Es teilt ungefähr die gleichen Artikel, es schreibt aber auch Freunden in dem Rhythmus, wie du Freunden schreibst, aber halt komplett mit nichtigen Themen. Beginnt Beziehungen, beendet Beziehungen, ganz normal. Beendet Beziehungen, aber genau in dem gleichen Rhythmus, wie du Beziehungen beendet und angefangen hast. Ja, vielleicht kann man das ja mathematisch machen, dass du einfach alle Bilder, die du hochgeladen hast, analysierst und du findest dann so einen Mittelwert, dass sie einfach analysiert werden, so übereinandergelegt werden. Die sind meistens blau. Und dann hast du einen Mittelwert und kannst dann sozusagen davon mit einem Zufallsgenerator dann so ein paar Parameter rumschubsen, so ein bisschen, so ein paar Regler schubsen nach links, nach rechts, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links, nach links ein Riesenproblem. Du kannst ja neue Fotos generieren. Fotos sind ja auch nur Pixel und Bits und Bytes und die kannst du ja einfach neu generieren, so wie du einfach dann die Norm zwischen zwei Fotos machst. Du meinst, wie du neuen Van Gogh malen kannst, einfach so. So meinst du. Ja, das ist ja auch so diese Theorie von Fatalismus und so. Wenn du genug Informationen gesammelt hast, ab einem gewissen Punkt hast du so viele Informationen, dass du die Zukunft voraussagen kannst. Wenn du die Mechanismen verstanden hast, wie diese Informationen zueinander passen und du hast Informationen gesammelt, kannst du ja ab dann alles automatisch einfach nach vorne rechnen. Was ist das Gegenteil von Fatalismus? Mutalismus. Aber ich finde es immer noch lustig, wenn diese Vorstellungen wissen, irgendjemand schreibt mir und sie sind sich nicht sicher, weil es hat sich auch rumgesprochen im Freundeskreis mittlerweile, dass man nur noch mit dem Botten schreibt, wenn man mit mir schreibt. Und sie wissen nicht genau, schreiben sie gerade mit mir oder mit dem Roboter. Ich finde das schon geil. Und es scannt auch, wie du Leute nennst. Das heißt, wenn du einen Florian immer Flo nennst, scannt das das und nennt ihn auch Flo. Ach, das ist ja geil. Aber bestimmt so mega penetrant. Weil es so stolz darauf ist, Flo herausgefunden zu haben, nennt es dann immer wegen jedem, das fängt es an mit Flo. Hey! Ihr habt ja gehört, dass solche künstlichen Intelligenzen von CIA oder sowas, die solche Intelligenzen entwickeln, dass die auch die teilweise getestet haben, zum Beispiel in World of Warcraft. Haben die einfach so Spieler erstellt, die einfach künstlich sind und die dann aber auch mit anderen Leuten chatten sollen und dann irgendwie Gespräche führen sollen und dann, ob dann, ob sich rausstellt, ob die dann die Leute abstossen und nicht denken, dass sie Bots oder wirklich... Was ja wirklich nicht schwer ist. Also in World of Warcraft hast du ja... Du hast ja trotzdem noch in dem Spielkosmos gewisse Sätze, die andauernd fallen, wie Ja, genau. Biete Wolle, kaufe Wolle, mehr Wolle. Ich würde gerne mehr Wolle haben, als ich verkaufe. Ich habe auch nur Wolle. Ich habe nicht so viel Wolle, aber ich hätte gerne mehr Wolle. Nee, stimmt schon. Deswegen, es kann gut sein, dass einige meiner intimsten Internetbekanntschaften
und meine Internetflirts in World of Warcraft einfach mit irgendwelchen CIA-Bots gestartet haben
und enge Freundschaften entstanden sind. Kann sein.
Hast du mal eine WoW-Beziehung gehabt?
Nein, nein, nein. Also natürlich hat man, man hat platonische Beziehungen, man hat natürlich,
es ist ein enger Bund innerhalb so einer Gilde.
Ich meine so eine Slash-Auszieh-Beziehung.
Achso, du meinst so eine, ja, ja. Wo man sich dann so eine Ecke stellt. Slash-Flirten-Beziehung meinst du. Und sich dann mal in so... Tandoria! Ich habe gestern Indisch gegessen, das ist irgendwie irgendwie drauf gekommen. Zieht sich immer durch, ja. Ja, wenn man so in Tandoria und dann plötzlich sich da so eine Mauer stellt und dann Slash-Ausziehen drückt, eingibt und dann sowas halt. Das habe ich dann oft gemacht, allerdings nur mit männlichen Spielern, die dann weibliche Figuren, ich habe immer eine weibliche Figur gespielt, das heißt, es waren dann Männer, die männliche Figuren gespielt haben. Was dann auch sexuell sehr kompliziert wird, das kann man auch nicht mehr googeln, so bin ich schwul, kann man noch googeln, aber angenommen Leute, ich bei W.O.W., ich ziehe mich aus, bin aber eine Frau, Und ich stehe darauf, wenn mein männliches Pendant ebenfalls eine Frau spielt, das kannst du nicht mehr stellen, die Frage. Ich war schon mal auf einer Hochzeit in World of Warcraft. Dann bin ich so in die Kirche gelaufen, muss dann eine Quest abgeben, und dann standen da so ganz viele Leute in Reihen, die alle da gekniet sind und so, und dann war so ein Brautpaar vorne und dann irgendwie so ein Priester, hat dann die Zeremonie gehalten. Waren die wirklich geheatet? Also ich glaube, dass die ja ingame geheiratet haben, aber kann schon sein. Also manchmal haben, wenn wirklich Leute heiraten, gibt es auch eine WoW-Hochzeit. Und dann kommst du da rein wie so ein unangemeldeter Gast und stehst dann da irgendwie mit deiner Rüstung und deinem Pferd und dann so. Und dein seltsamen Feuerwerk-Gimmick, was du bekommen hast, weil du seit zwei Jahren spielst. Ja genau, mit deinem Roboterhelm. Also Sachen, der dann immer so obszöde Sachen schreit, durch die gegen Feuerbälle schießt. Und dann stehst du da erstmal so und dann denkst du, oh scheiße, fuck. Kann der Taucher mit dem Sombrero bitte gehen jetzt?
Ja, ja. Es gibt ja auch so grosse World of Warcraft-Skandale der WoW-Geschichte.
Und einmal ist tatsächlich von einer recht grossen Gilde ein Spieler gestorben.
Also der Spieler ist gestorben. In Game.
Nee, in echt, er ist gestorben.
Und dann gab es eine grosse Trauerfeier.
Und dann hat diese ganze Gilde sich an so einem See, irgendwie in so einer tollen Landschaft, da hat sich so eine Trauerfeier gesammelt und alle kamen an. Allerdings hat die gegnerische Fraktion auf dem Server, es gibt immer Horde und Allianz, die im Krieg stehen, hat das halt mitbekommen und haben halt einen riesigen Raid organisiert und sind da halt hingeritten und haben die halt alle niedergemäht, weil die hatten halt alle ihre Waffen abgelegt und so und so zeremonielle Gewänder angelegt und so und dann kamen halt die Orks und tauchen und haben die einfach überrannt und haben die einfach immer und immer wieder getötet und haben sich dann irgendwie so auf die Gesichter gesetzt und da rumgetanzt und so und es ist halt wirklich in echt jemand gestorben, einfach so, das ist einfach so knallhart. Ja, aber auch nicht, aber es ist halt im Spiel nicht, also es ist trotzdem irgendwie lustig, weil es lächerlich ist. Es ist mega lustig, natürlich, weil es einfach so brutal ist irgendwie, dann so keine Gnade dem Feind. Da ist dann auch einfach nur noch ein Spiel und man muss ja, ich weiss nicht, ob ich das, würdest du es wollen? Es ist eine neue Erweiterung übrigens rausgekommen, hast du mir erzählt. Ich weiss, ja, deswegen sieht man mich auch kaum noch in der Sonne nicht. Und deswegen ist es auch nicht so off-topic, also wenn ihr denkt, oh, diese beiden Genies reden wieder von irgendwelchen Dingen off-topic, nein. Ja. Stefan hat gerade den Funny-Mode aktiviert, indem er seinen Stuhl arretiert hat und so, this is going down. Was habe ich gemacht? Sie sind arretiert. Ich habe meinen Stuhl? Arretiert. Irritiert. Arretiert ist ein Wort? Ich habe noch nie gehört, das Wort. Kann gut sein, arritiert. Du kennst manchmal lustige Wörter. Kann gut sein, Worte. Nee, nee, war schon richtig. Aber das ist echt, also dieses Social-Media-Bot finde ich ganz schön cool, weil da gibt es auch diese Geschichte, weiss nicht, haben wir auch schon mal vielleicht drüber gesprochen, aber dieses Microsoft-Bot, was die bei Twitter aktiviert haben und sollte halt von den Leuten lernen, die das angetwittert haben. Und es wurde halt innerhalb von 24 Stunden von, der erste Tweet war, ich liebe Menschen, und der letzte Tweet, bevor sie es abschalten mussten, war irgendwie, I wish Hitler was alive oder sowas. Ja, und Death to all Jews. Death to the Jews. Vor allem, ich finde, dass, bevor sie es abschalten mussten, so, was passiert, es fängt an, irgendwie wild Leute zu liken oder so, was das Schlimlimmste, das passieren könnte so ein Twitter-Board? Es kann einfach nichts passieren. Die haben ja bestimmte Jahre daran gearbeitet, an diesem Twitter-Board. Microsoft halt. Also weltführende Programmierer haben daran gesessen, haben sich darauf gefreut, haben ihren Familien am Tisch erzählt, oh, morgen geht es endlich online, yay, und die Kinder, what, ich bin so stolz auf dich, Papa, und dann stellen sie es online und am nächsten Tag, am nächsten Tag, während sie zwei Jahre davor gearbeitet haben, mussten sie es schon abstellen, weil es nicht Jugendgeleid ist. Haben sie ein Monster geschaffen. Weil sie genoziert und den Holocaust geläugnet, das ist eigentlich. Wirklich. Ich finde, wenn jemand den Holocaust nicht leugnen sollte, dann die Artificial Intelligence. Das stimmt. Das ist ein Fakt. Sagst du. Sag ich auch. Du bist ja auch ein anderer Meinung. Ja, das fand ich schon echt ganz cool. Also wenn es irgendwann rauskommt, dieses Board, dann will ich es auf jeden Fall haben. Es gratuliert auch Leuten zum Geburtstag und so. Und sind wir mal ehrlich, Facebook besteht nur daraus, dass man Leuten zum Leuten so bewusst gratuliert. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Sorry, tut mir leid, dass ich immer wieder auf WoW komme, aber die neue Erweiterung ist halt gerade draußen. Es gibt auch bei WoW so Add-ons, Plugins, die du installieren kannst. Und da gibt es halt auch Chat-Plugins, die halt immer, wenn ein anderer Spieler online kommt, aus der Gilde, dann schreibt er halt Hallo und den Namen des Spielers. Aber das merkst du ja, dass das nur ein Bot ist, wenn es bei jedem Spieler konstant immer passiert, wo man dann auch wirklich, also wo dann auch irgendwie, wenn jemand so ein Achievement erreicht, also irgendwas Tolles schafft, dann wird das auch in den Chat gepostet und dann schreibt man jemanden, herzlichen Glückwunsch darunter, wo ich dann auch die Leute angeschrieben habe, so, ja Leute, also so funktioniert das doch nicht, das ist doch nicht der Sinn von Höflichkeit, dass du es automatisierst, das bringt doch nichts. Hast du versucht, WoW ein bisschen menschlicher zu machen? Nein, also innerhalb meiner Gilder, ich kannte die Leute ja auch und die hat dann mir so, man sieht ja, also wenn man das irgendwie cleverer machen könnte, dass man es nicht sieht, aber man sieht ja, dass es ein Bot ist.
Also das nimmt ja den Effekt von Höflichkeit komplett raus und macht den eigentlich, also ironisiert ihn fast, dass man sagt so, ich beauftrage eine Maschine, dir alles Gutes zum Gurtstag zu wünschen, jedes Jahr, das ist ja nicht der Sinn.
Aber deswegen will ich der Erste sein, der das Bot hat. Weil dann ist es ja irgendwie höflich. Wenn man weiß, dass es ein Bot ist. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Es ist aber noch immer zumindest höflich, weil ich denke an euch alle, indem ich mir jetzt dieses Bot installiere. Ach so, genau. Ja, das ist mein Geschenk an die gesamte Menschheit. Ich mache kurz was und dann kreischen Glückwunsch an alle schon mal. Also die Frage, ob es höflich ist, dass du einen höflicheren Bot installierst. So weiss der ist höflicher als ich, deswegen soll der das machen, was ja eigentlich der Höflichkeit zuträglich ist, einfach mehr Höflichkeit in die Welt bringen. Oder ob man ein dummes Arschloch bei jedem Achievement schreibt, um die anderen Bots aufzuwerten. Das stimmt, also ein bisschen runterholen einfach. Das kann man alles, alles möglich. Alles möglich. Die moderne Technik. Aber du hast die letzten Tage, hast du viel gezockt? Ja, ne? Du musst mal wieder ordentlich gehen. Aber hast du lange nicht mehr gemacht, oder? Ja, ja, und ich bin auch da nicht mehr so drin. Also früher einfach das Wochenende durchgesuchtet, mittlerweile ist man da nicht mehr, man hat natürlich auch nicht die Zeit und andere Verpflichtungen, aber man ist auch nicht mehr so, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt einfach zehn Stunden die Nacht durch, weil früher war es halt dann einfach so, du hast dir überlegt, okay, ich könnte die Nacht schlafen, und aber auch W-W-Zocken. Und dann hast du einfach zwei, drei Nächte die Woche nicht geschlafen, einfach weil du es auch noch ausgehalten hast und hast du einfach durchgezockt dann die ganze Zeit. Das würde ich jetzt nicht mehr machen, weil es jetzt auch wichtiger ist, was man tagsüber macht. So früher in der Schule, ein Schultag hätte es, du Dösen war vollkommen in Ordnung, das hat überhaupt keinen Unterschied gemacht.
Und heute kannst du das eigentlich nicht machen.
Ich habe mal so ein Browser-Game angefangen, Browser-Game, wo man so andere, so Clash of Clans oder sowas, ähnliches, es hies aber anders, die Stämme war das, glaube ich. Und dann bin ich in so einer sehr, sehr ehrgeizigen Gilde gelandet und dann wurde ich zum Gildensprecher gemacht.
Nee, nicht zum Gildensprecher, ich wurde zum halt so ein HR, ich wurde zum Personaler gemacht und musste Leute rekrutieren und so. Dann habe ich wirklich Aufgaben bekommen. Ich habe das zwei Tage gespielt und plötzlich war ich in so einem Aufgabendschungel gefangen und musste mir im Kalender auch so Termine anlegen und so, wo ich mir dachte, das wollte ich mit dem Spiel eigentlich nicht erreichen. Ich wurde ja so ein bisschen so neben dem Fernsehen daddeln und dann aber plötzlich habe ich Aufgaben bekommen. Und ich finde immer dann, er überschreitet so ein Spiel auch gewisse Grenzen. Also deswegen, ich verstehe immer nicht, wie man dann, du warst auch mal Guilden-Sprecher oder was du erzählt, was ich niemals machen würde, weil dann hast du doch, also dann steigst du eine Parallelwelt ein, aber das Coole an Spielen ist doch eben keine Parallel zu sein. Ja doch, aber es kommt mir darauf an, ob du komplexe oder einfache Spiele magst, sondern ich bin halt immer Fan von komplexen Spielen, dass du dich halt wirklich da reinarbeitest. Wow, du hast mich da jetzt auch zu einem Arschloch gemacht. Ja, absolut, ja. Nee, aber auch, ich war einmal Versorgungsoffizier, einmal Nachwuchsoffizier und einmal Gensprecher, das war den höchsten Rang, Rang, den ich je hatte. Und das ist ja wirklich, es macht ja schon Spaß, weil du hast ja auch eine gewisse Autorität. Ja, aber du kannst ja auch als Nachwuchsoffizier... Du hast ja doch mehr davon Autorität. Naja, gut, aber wenn du im echten Leben halt irgendwie in der Schule bist als 17-Jähriger, dann ist es cool, wenn du im digitalen Leben darüber entscheiden kannst, ob jetzt jemand in die Gilde eintritt oder nicht. Und da steht dann so ein 32-Jähriger, der sich bei dir bewerben muss und eine E-Mail schreibt, eine echte E-Mail und schreibt, ich würde gerne in eurer Gilde sein, ich habe die und die Erfahrung und ich spiele so und so viel am Tag und du schreibst dann zurück, ja irgendwie und wie sieht es aus mit deinem Job, wenn da mal was ist, kannst du dann trotzdem noch spielen oder musst du dann zu deinem Job? Ja, ich muss dann schon meinen Job, aha und wie ist es mit deiner Frau, wenn du irgendwie ein Kind kriegst oder so, dann musst du abends weg oder was? Naja, auch nicht unbedingt, ja, wir melden uns. Und dann kannst du dann einfach das grösste Arschloch der Welt sein. Das finde ich nicht schlecht, wenn man diese Bewerbungsgespräche auch so Online-Rollen spielen, meines echte Leben überträgt, wenn so ein 13-jähriger Vollarsch sitzt, der sich freut, einfach mal ein bisschen Autorität zu genießen und dann aber bewirbt sich so ein 30-jähriger gestandener Bürokaufmann oder so. Ja, natürlich. Das sind ja wirklich teilweise erfolgreiche Leute, aber die halt einfach dadurch, dass sie so viel arbeiten müssen, halt weniger Erfolg in WoW haben. Und du als Schüler, der nichts erreicht hat, bist du halt total der Gegend. Sie werden durch ihr Erfolg im Leben bestraft, im Online-Rollenspiel nicht so viel Erfolg zu haben. Es ist eine komplett umgekehrte Gesellschaft, die Verlierer, die Gewinner und die Gewinner, die Verlierer sind. Und Orks. Und Orks. Aber das macht schon Spaß einfach so, dass dann sind. Bist du ja drin und du suchst dann halt, wenn du halt zweiter Auswahl hast und einer ist arbeitslos, dann nimmst du natürlich den arbeitslos. Das ist ja schon klar. Das ist komplett die andere Welt. Ja, genau. Das ist ja so. Aber das fand ich so unangenehm. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich es so unangenehm fand, so viel Autorität zu genießen, plötzlich in die Stämme. Weil ich weiß nicht. Die Stämme auch ein scheiß Spiel ist. Ja, aber auf der auf der einen Sitzte, ja, du kannst auch nicht, vor allem wie WoW, du kannst nicht immer drin sitzen, du bist dann halt mal drin, also du kannst ja nicht viel machen, du kannst dann mal, okay, jetzt habe ich genug Stein, jetzt kann ich auf okay drücken und dann wird die Mauer gebaut, du hast ja nicht so viel Macht, und trotzdem hatte ich trotzdem sehr viel Macht, plötzlich über diese seltsame Gilde. Ja, ich weiss, wie hies dieses Spiel damals so mit, wo man so einen Garten hatte? Farmville. Naja, vor Farmville noch irgendwie so. Da gab es irgendwie so... Alphaville. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Smallville. Auf geht's, ab geht's, drei Tage wach. Bitte. Da war das gerade aktuell. Das habe ich immer gehört, während ich das gespielt habe. Das war irgendwie so... Das hatte so einen scheiß deutschen Namen. Früher hatten ja alle Dinge auch deutsche Namen. so die lokalisten.de war das Facebook und früher gab es dann auch die wilden Kerle die wilden Kerle, ja, statt Guardians of the Galaxy, so was und ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was es war und da waren wir sogar im Urlaub, beim Campen und dann ist ein Freund von uns, ist mitten beim Campen, ist nach Hause gefahren und hat für alle sozusagen die Sachen geerntet und neue Sachen gepflanzt. Und dann musste jeder ihm sein Passwort geben und er hatte so eine lange Liste mit allen und seinem Passwort. Und er ist dann in der Woche nach Hause geradelt und hat dann sich da hingelockt und hat sich bei allen eingelockt. Und ich habe halt nur ein Passwort für alles. Und ich musste mir dann echt überlegen, gebe ich jetzt mein Passwort her für alles, was ich habe. Kannst du dir jetzt verraten, dein Passwort war damals für alles? Nee, ich habe immer noch dasselbe. Immer noch dasselbe. Also das, was du dem Freund damals gegeben hast. Ja. Wenn er das jetzt hört, die Folge, dann kann er alles verändern. Wird die Puffopedia jetzt komplett gelöscht werden wahrscheinlich. Die Leiche wird endlich begraben. Unsere Seite war daumen. Ja, unsere Seite war daumen. Aber nur weil der Server umgezogen ist und die hätten uns Bescheid gesagt früh genug. War nicht unser Fehler, wir konnten da nichts dazu zu tun, aber ist in Ordnung. Wir hätten Bescheid sagen können, ist okay, ist okay, ist ein Hobbyprojekt immer noch. Aber bei mir war es damals auch so, wir waren alle bei Knuddels so mega drin, das war halt so unser Ding. Ist das nicht so eine Dating-Plattform, Knuddels? Nein, das ist eine Chat-Plattform. Also vielleicht ist es jetzt so ein bisschen verhunzt, aber es war damals halt noch einfach für Schüler so eine Chat-Plattform. Und da musste man halt, um ein angesehenes Family-Mitglied zu sein, ein paar Mal im Monat zumindest sich einloggen. Und da musste man auch immer, wenn wir in den Urlaub gefahren sind, haben wir die Passwörter gegeben und dann wurde das halt gepflegter Account von Freunden, was problematisch ist, weil es halt wirklich, weil man da hat man auch Mädchen kennen gelernt und man hat so die, weiß nicht, so die ersten Dinge ausgetauscht, äh, Wörter, also keine Bilder, es klang gerade, es klang gerade, es klang gerade grösser als es war. Und der Stefan und die Miriam, die haben sich schon Sätze geschaffen, und auch Satzzeichen. Die haben sich schon ein Smiley gescheckt! Und das weiß ich noch, da haben dann zwei Freunde von mir einen Schabernack getrieben mit meinem Account, als ich noch da war, da war ich noch nicht im Urlaub. Und dann bin ich, für mich ist da die Welt zusammengebrochen, wie die beiden mich hintergehen konnten. Mit meinem Account, kein Scheiss, Spy94. Und dann bin ich mit meinem, dann bin ich aufs Fahrrad, ich bin schreiend aus dem Haus gerannt, habe mein Fahrrad genommen, meine Eltern hinterher, was macht das Kind denn? Und dann bin ich ohne Schuhe, ohne alles, bin ich auf mein Fahrrad gestiegen einfach und bin so mit dem Kumpel gerast und habe den Computer aus der Hand gerissen und habe dann da meine Passwort wieder geändert, weil die halt Schabernack getrieben haben. Aber was haben die für Schabernack getrieben? Ich glaube, die haben das Passwort geändert einfach. Sag mal, was findest du eigentlich, mal eine kurze intimere Frage, aber wenn man in einer Beziehung ist, was findest du da eigentlich wichtiger? Findest du den Sex wichtiger oder das Küssen wichtiger? Es spielst gerade an, als ich meinen Artikel geteilt habe. Das war der mehrkwürdigste Moment meines Lebens, wo ich dachte, okay, jetzt ist Stefan völlig verloren. Ja, man muss dazu sagen, ich bin nachts bei Facebook gewesen, nachts vor allem, und habe dann aus Versehen... Niemand ist nachts bei Facebook, du warst ganz alleine. ...habe gescrollt und manchmal hat mein PC so ganz seltsame Momente und dann bin ich aus den Teilen gekommen bei dem einen seltsamen Artikel in meiner Feedline, Timeline, und zwar ähm, nee, was war das nochmal? Ein Weissartikel, glaube ich. Ein Weissartikel, was liest du denn nochmal? Frauen? Nee, ich glaube wirklich so dieses, nee, ich glaube es war sogar die Aussage, Küssen ist in der Beziehung wichtiger als Sex. Oder es war als Frage formuliert, aber ich glaube es war sogar als Aussage formuliert. Und dann ist bei allen Freunden der Weissartikel, es hat auch beim ersten Gefällt mir, dachte ich mir so, okay, da ist was schief gelaufen. Dann kamen so Fragen, wenn Stefan Tietze den Artikel, Küssen ist wichtiger in der Beziehung als Sex ist, weiss man, da ist irgendwas im Busch. Ja, ich habe für einen kurzen Moment gedacht so, du teilst ja wirklich recht wenig eigentlich, wenn dann mal irgendwie Le Miserable sind schon wieder in Dortmund unterwegs zum dritten Mal und du hast doch jemand Karten, hat doch jemand Karten die ganze Zeit, aber ansonsten passiert ja auf deiner Facebookseite nicht viel und dann mitten in der Nacht, ist das jetzt so ein selbstzerstörerischer, er gibt sich einfach den Wölfen des Internets hin und sagt, frisst mich und ich teile das jetzt einfach. Weil das war auch der bescheuertste Artikel der Welt natürlich, fucking Weisheit. Aber das Gute als Comedy-Persona ist, man kann eigentlich alles machen. Ja, aber bist du auf deinem privaten Facebook-Account eine Comedy-Persona? Also eigentlich nicht so, da kommen nicht so wahnsinnig viele geckige Sachen bei rum. Aber das ist natürlich schon ein guter Move, so einfach zu sagen, Küssen ist ein bisschen nachhause, ja das finde ich auch. Und diese Teilaktion, was sagt die denn auch aus, das finde ich exakt, das ist auch meine Meinung. Das ist ja auch ein interessanter Punkt, was Leute sagen wollen, wenn sie Dinge einfach nur teilen. Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie etwas einfach nur so geteilt, sondern schreibt dann immer dazu. Also ist ja dann eigentlich egal, wenn man sagt, hey, guckt euch das an, muss man ja eigentlich nicht dazu schreiben, wenn man was teilt, weil das sagt ja schon die Handlung des Teilens aus eigentlich. Aber man kann sich ganz immer fragen, was wollen Leute damit aussagen? Ja, das stimmt. Es hat keine Aussage, es hat einfach nur so ein, es gibt es auch im echten Leben nicht so eins, Wenn man hört etwas und sagt es dann eins zu eins genau so nochmal in eine andere Richtung.
Im echten Leben hast du ja immer einen Adressaten.
Da gehst du zu einem Freund und sagst, ich habe diesen geilen Weissartikel gelesen,
über Küssen und Sex haben, liest ihn immer durch, der ist total interessant.
Aber im echten Leben sagst du es ja nicht so in die Welt hinaus, sondern immer einer Person.
Und so ist ja die Frage, dadurch, dass du keinen klaren Adressaten hast,
ist die Botschaft natürlich eher so, fällt auch wieder stark auf dich zurück.
Das ist ein, was alle Freunde gleich behandelt. Ja, das stimmt. Weil das macht dich zu einer anderen Person. Deswegen ist unsere Generation auch so verkorkst. Ich mag das nicht zu sagen, aber ich hasse das zu sagen, weil das so eine mega Mainstream-Meinung ist und das aber auch unsere Generation sagt. Und ja, das stimmt aber, weil wir immer gelernt haben, alle gleich zu behandeln irgendwie, was man nicht tut, das ist unmenschlich, das macht man nicht. Aber durch Social Media lernt man halt so einen gemeinsamen Nenner finden zu wollen. Man sagt Dinge, die man allen sagen würde, man teilt Dinge, die man nur allen teilen würde. Und wenn einer dabei ist, bei dem man das nicht sagen würde, vor dem man nicht den Artikel Küssen ist wichtiger als Sex teilen würde, würde man es normalerweise auch nicht machen. Ja, das stimmt. Das heißt, man hat einen sehr limitierten Bereich, was man überhaupt sagt bei Facebook,
und das formt einen als Menschen ja auch irgendwie zu etwas ganz Seltsamem.
Ja.
Herzlich willkommen bei der Philosophischen Stunde.
Ja, manchmal sind solche Teilen ja auch so indirekt gerichtet.
Du teilst es, aber willst eigentlich nur, dass eine andere Person es liest,
also dass die süße Lisa aus der Parallelklasse liest, was du für ein sophisticated guter Küsse bist und wie wichtig die Romantik in der Beziehung ist.
Wenn ich jetzt eine Freundin hätte und es läuft nicht mehr so gut im Bett und ich würde dann den Artikel teilen, Küssen ist wichtiger als Sex, das wäre was.
Ja, das stimmt. Sex ist gar nicht so wichtig.
Oder so, die Schwiegereltern am Wochenende zu besuchen ist gar nicht so wichtig für eine Beziehung.
Hm, very specific, okay, danke Stefan.
Ich habe irgendwas entdeckt, wenn man Doppel auf Fn drückt, kann man diktieren.
Und ich habe am Wochenende meinen Partikumsbericht fertig geschrieben, und ich habe dann irgendwann mal ausversichtlich Doppel auf Fn gedrückt und hatte dann diese Diktierfunktion an und habe dann den ganzen Text einfach nur eingesprochen, was dazu führte, dass ich das ganze Wochenende mit meinem Computer geredet habe, Monolog gehalten habe und es hat zwar viel länger gedauert, weil ich auf jeden Punkt, jeden Absatz und so mit sprechen muss. Ja und du musst es ja nicht danach editieren, oder? Das ist ja nicht so gut, die Sprache. Das ist nicht so gut, nee, nee. Es hat mich wirklich um Jahre zurückgeworfen, was die Schnelligkeit angeht, mit der man Texte schreiben kann, aber ich habe es natürlich gemacht, weil es einfach cooler ist.
Ja.
Das ist einfach das coolere Gefühl. Irgendwie eine geniale King of Queens Folge. Die Top 3 King of Queens Folgen. Okay, kriegen wir sogar hin, oder? Nee. Aber Top 1 bei mir wäre, Doug und Carrie schreibt für diese Anwaltgehilfin und schreibt irgendwie so Sachen, die der Anwalt diktiert hat, indem sie es auch diktiert, weil sie hat so ein Mikrofon geschenkt bekommen, wo sie dann mit ihrem Computer was diktieren kann. Und dann streiten sich Doug und Carrie und das Ding nimmt den ganzen Streit auf, dannücken die es aus und tragen es dann noch mal vor.
Ja, und lesen den Streit noch mal durch. Genau, und dann kommt Arthur noch rein und liest er nach das nach und spricht auch noch was rein. Das ist wirklich lustig. Ja, das ist echt nicht schlecht, wenn man so einen ganzen Streit mit seiner Freundin komplett aufgeschrieben hätte und dann einfach durchlesen könnte. Das ist schon interessant eigentlich. Ich fand die Folge sehr gut mit dem Sandwichladen, wo Doug fast seinen eigenen Sandwichladen gehabt hätte, aber dann seinen Bruder es bekommen hat und am Ende dann Carrie noch so das Sandwich durchschneidet und das halbe Sandwich so hinrückt. Da dachte ich mir immer, das ist die perfekte Beziehung. Dicker, lustiger Mann und schöne, schlanke Frau, dachte ich mir, genau so kann ich mir das vorstellen. Das ist der Nachteil der Serie, es suggeriert, dass jeder Mann jede Frau haben kann. Was jetzt auch keine so schlechte Botschaft ist, wenn man auch sagt, dass jede Frau jeden Mann haben kann, aber du siehst selten Serien, in denen eine hässliche Frau einen hübschen Mann hat. Ja, das ist eine scharfe Gesellschaftskritik. Allerdings, Messerscharf. Messerscharf. An die Welt da draußen. Ich habe es geträumt. Vielleicht einfach mal, wir hatten diese Rubrik ja schon ein paar Mal und ich würde mir wünschen, wenn einfach so ein paar Interpretationen vielleicht kommen von euch, ein paar Analysen, was das zu bedeuten hat. Es war in Berlin, die Sto-Spiel in Berlin. Ich bin nachts rumgelaufen, brauchte dann ein Auto, habe mir ein Car2Go geholt, wo dann Frau Angela Merkel an diesem Car2Go-Auto stand. Das war ein Smart, dieser kleine Smart42, der neue. Und dann stand Frau Merkel an diesem Auto, wollte ebenfalls das Car2Go haben. Da dachte ich mir schon, ach Gott, jetzt ist das ja schon jemand an einem Car2Go. Sie hat es aber nicht aufbekommen. Dann habe ich gesagt, ach, Frau Merkel, ja, ich kann sie auch einfach mitnehmen, kein Problem. Und dann bin ich mit Frau Merkel im Car2Go die ganze Nacht durch Berlin gefahren. Sie hat mir die Stadt erklärt, sie hat mir ein bisschen von ihrem Job erzählt. Es war auch kein spannendes Gespräch, es waren auch so ein bisschen zwei fremde Menschen, die sie halt zuerst mal kennenlernen. Hast du ihr auch von deinem Job erklärt? Ja, auch so ein bisschen von meinem Leben erzählt. Wie ich laufs Studium, dann habe ich von meinem Studium erzählt und von meinem Job und ich habe einen Podcast und dann hat sie mir erzählt, was sie so macht. Hast du die eingeleladenen Podcast? Nein. Oh Stefan! Nein, da halte ich Angst für Angst. Mann! Und dann aber dann, es war so ein dafür, für das Setting, für das Grundsetting so ein unspektakulärer Traum, erschreckend. Dann sind wir einfach ein bisschen durch Berlin gefahren, dann habe ich sie abgesetzt im Kanzleramt und dann bin ich weitergefahren, nach Hause. Ich weiss gar nicht, ob ich, wenn ich mit Angela Merkel reden würde, auch von mir erzählen würde, weil ich mir denke, das ist ja doch alles scheißegal. Also ich meine, natürlich ist es doch nur ein Mensch, aber wenn sie sagt, ja, ich habe jetzt die diplomatische Beziehung mit Russland und habe gerade den Dritten Weltkrieg verhindert und ich so, ich habe mein Fahrrad, da ist jetzt, also ich habe mir schon eine Pumpe gekauft. Aber die Klingel ist abgebrochen. Die Klingel ist abgebrochen und ich habe auch nicht das richtige Ventil für diese Pumpe, sondern ich habe, also ich habe zwei Ventile und das eine ist zu klein und das andere ist zu gross. Und jetzt wächst sich immer zwischen den Hin und Her. Das Problem ist, wenn du das Ventil reindrückst, dann geht ja erstmal Luft raus. Und wenn du es dann nicht schaffst, neue Luft reinzupumpen, dann ist ja bei jedem Pumpversuch geht mehr Luft raus. Das heißt, du musst dir jedes Mal überlegen, riskiere ich es, es nochmal neu zu versuchen. Und jetzt mittlerweile sind meine beiden Reifen vorne und hinten halbleer und ich eier da durch die Gegend wie so auf nassen Säcken, eier ich da durch die Gegend wie so ein Dödel und schlag mir bei jeder Bordsteinkante dann irgendwie den Schlauch auf. Und das ist nicht schön. Und Sie haben die Währungsreform jetzt durchgesetzt und irgendwie den Schuldenschnitt beschlossen, oder wie, oder? Ich habe ungefähr zwei Milliarden Menschen vor dem sicheren Hungertod gerettet. Ach geil. Das war erst gestern. Ach was? Heute wiederum versuche ich die Beziehung mit den USA wieder ein bisschen nach vorne zu ficken, um da einfach noch mal ein bisschen das Freihandelsabkommen nach vorne zu pushen. Und ja, ich glaube, da werden wir alle und auch viele Generationen nach uns profitieren. Aber zurück zu dem Reifen. Kann man das noch verhindern, das Freihandelsabkommen eigentlich? Ja. Also du jetzt nicht, aber ja. Okay. Und diese ganzen Demos und Protesten, so bringt das eigentlich was? Ich bitte dich. Bin ich doch Frau Merkel eigentlich oder bin ich für Stefan, der Politik interessierte TTIP-Gegner? Bist du gegen TTIP? Ist dir scheissegeil? Ich habe darüber recherchiert, tatsächlich. Ja, recherchiert haben wir alle, wir haben uns alle dieses eine YouTube-Video angeguckt, in dem erklärt wird, was das alles ist und wie böse das ist. Ich habe ein Projekt dabei geschrieben, eine Recherche um TTIP, weil Bertelsmann hat eine Studie herausgebracht, wie toll TTIP ist, sie aber als Unternehmen mega davon profitieren. Und dann habe ich versucht zu recherchieren gegen Battlesman, was absolut nicht möglich ist, weil es ein krasses Riesenunternehmen ist und man keine Ahnung hat, wie viel Macht Battlesman hat und so. Und das war extrem gruselig, das war extrem crazy, aber ich sag mal, Journalismus ist mega spannend. Wow! Ich habe nichts rausgefunden, ich habe irgendwie 16 Mal beim Inder bestellt, ich habe mega Schulden, aber ich liebe Journalismus. Mega zugenommen und ich liebe Journalismus. Das ist einfach genau meins. Ich weiß einfach, dass es genau das Richtige ist für mich. Sagt er und kratzte an seinem Kratzeis. And scene. Da sagt nochmal jemand, wir können keine Hörspiele, Leute. Wenn das nicht ein geiles Angela Merkel-Hörspiel weiter, dann geht man auch nicht weiter, du Freunde. Hättet ihr Interesse an einem Podcast, der sich nur um Hörspiele dreht? Nein. Schreibt uns eine Mail an www. Stimmt an, zentral an podcast-ufo.fl. Wir bekommen so gut wie gar keine Mails, wir bekommen nur diese komischen Snaps und diese komischen Sachen auf YouTube und sowas, aber überhaupt nichts per Mail. Ich habe gestern Snapchat mal öffentlich gemacht. Wie heisst du denn auf Snapchat? Esteban Tithios. Wie heisst du denn auf Snapchat? Ich heisse Stefan Titzer auf Snapchat. Das ist ein Riesenproblem, tatsächlich. Ich kann keine Brand aufbauen. Ich auch nicht! Das Problem bei mir ist, du kannst dich ja Stefan Tingler nennen, das ist ja kein Ding. Ich bin immer mit Stefan Titzer gefangen. Für mich ist der Name wesentlich schädlicher als für dich. Soll ich mich jetzt irgendwie dafür entschuldigen, dass du so dumm bist, Snapchat zu bedienen? Das ist was wir gerade plötzlich sehr ernst hier. Aus unvergleichen Gründen müssen wir einen Grossteil jetzt rausschneiden. Wir müssen uns in die Haare bekommen. Die nächsten zweieinhalb Stunden rausschneiden, irgendwie komischerweise. Aber haben wir uns eigentlich jemals gestritten, wirklich? Nee, aber haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal besprochen, weil wir beide so reflektiv sind, oder? Weil wir beide so grammatikonisch sind. Aber beide so gut deutschsprachend. Ja, da ist kein Gag mehr drin in den letzten Sätzen. Nee, ist okay. Aber nee, aber nicht so richtig, ne? Man hat manchmal so Spannungen, einfach emotional. Du bist ein sehr unemotionaler Mensch. Bei dir gibt es selten emotionale Spannungen.
Findest du? Ja, letztes, als du auf diese
Bestellung gewartet hast, da warst du ein bisschen
hibbelig. Aber ansonsten, dein ganzes
Leben dreht sich eigentlich nur
um Pakete und Amazon,
Bestellungen und hier und Sachen
hier und dort. Ich habe neulich überlegt,
dass ich vielleicht eine Krankheit habe. Ja, welche denn?
So eine Krankheit, dass man zu viel kauft. Kaufkrankheit, Kaufsucht. Ja, weil ich bestelle sehr viel und ich will damit bestimmt auch viele Lücken füllen, die ich in meinem Leben finde. Kaufhusten. Und vielleicht habe ich da einfach Kaufhusten, den Keuchhusten, das ist ein Wortspiel, ne? Kauf. Aber wirklich, also ist es zwanghaft bei dir? Nein, nicht zwanghaft. Also musst du bestellen? Ja, aber ja schon, aber auch weil viele Dinge anfallen.
Also ich sehe da durchaus Potenzial, weil ich muss sagen, als du letztens so in einem Nebensatz so wegwerfend erwähnt hast, dass du eine Posaune bestellt hast. Ja. Spätestens da dachte ich mir, hmm. Aber das ist ein altes Hobby, was ein bisschen der Theorie zuspricht, dass ich vielleicht ein Riesenproblem habe, dass ich mir oft, also dass ich mir jedes Jahr so ein Instrument kaufe. Also da spare ich dann auch drauf. Und dann hole ich mir jedes Jahr ein Instrument. Du hast gesagt, du hast die billigste Posaune gekauft, die du finden konntest. Ich bestelle mir, ich habe mir die billigste Geige schon bestellt. Ich spar auf die billigste Posaune. Ich habe mir die billigste Geige, die ich finden konnte, bestellt vor ein paar Jahren. Jetzt habe ich mir die billigste Posaune, die ich finden konnte, bestellt. Und das macht schon Spaß. Ich bin aber auch ein sehr musikalischer Typ. Man muss ein absolutes Gehör manchmal ein bisschen füttern mit verschiedenen Instrumenten, neuen Herausforderungen, neuen Challenges. Und ich denke, die Posaune war jetzt der nächste Schritt in Richtung Vollendung meines musikalischen Genies. Bist du doch Geige? Geige war ein riesen Problem, weil ich habe das nicht mehr, ich bin über wie halte ich das Instrument richtig nie hinausgekommen. Ja. Ich habe ein paar Melodien gespielt, aber habe bestimmt falsch, aber ja. Posaune habe ich mir jetzt mit so einem YouTube-Tutorial besser angeeignet, glaube ich.
Also es klappt schon ganz gut.
Manchmal kommen, manchmal, also ich habe so ein paar Melodien, die ich mir drauf schaffe jetzt, um einfach so ein bisschen die Mechanik kennenzulernen. Weil es ist extrem heftig. Ich dachte immer, dass man hat ja so ein Posaunen, das Instrument, wo man so eine Slide hat, so eine Rutsche, die man immer raus und wieder reinschieben kann. Und ich dachte, dass alle Töne, die man damit machen kann, erzeugt, indem man die Slide ein bisschen verschiebt. Weil je länger die raus ist, desto tiefer muss natürlich der Ton sein, weil die Wellenlängen, die sich bilden können, länger sind. Und ist aber nicht so. In jeder verschiedenen Stellung, es gibt nämlich nur sieben Stellungen, und in jeder kann es so ungefähr vier, fünf Töne erzeugen, je nachdem wie schnell du deine Lippen vibrieren lässt. Also ob du machst oder und das habe ich noch nicht ganz raus, das ist extrem schwierig. Also du kannst wirklich mit einer Position fünf Töne erzeugen, je nachdem wie doll du da reinbläst. Aber das sind dann Oktaven einfach von derselben Ton, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, habe ich auch noch nicht ganz durch.
Dem Quintenzirkel aber entsprechend.
Das ist spannend. Mathematik ist spannend.
Aber das ist, kann ich mir jedem empfehlen.
Das hilft aber, glaube ich, so rein fürs logische Denken, fürs, ich weiß nicht,
ich glaube, es hilft einfach dem Gehirn auch, wenn man ab und zu ein neues Instrument lernt.
Auf jeden Fall, klar, neue Sprachen lernen, neue Instrumente lernen, ist immer gut. Wir haben neulich im Redaktionsraum gesessen und dann kamen wir irgendwie auf dieses most satisfying video of all time, of the world, und da kam irgendwann auch so eine Kettenreaktion drin vor, wo mir auffiel, die besten Momente meiner Kindheit hatte ich eigentlich immer Freitagsabends beim Domino Day. Ja, Domino Day habe ich jedes Jahr mit meinem Vater gesehen, war immer ein grosses Highlight. Riesen Highlight. Ich bin immer so fasziniert von diesem Pendeln, dass diese Pendeln und dann die Werbeeinblendung. Und vor allem teilweise hat die Werbung zu lange gedauert und dann kamen die schon zurück und dann war schon wieder was umgefallen. Und dann ging es aber nicht weiter, was immer so merkwürdig war, weil ich dachte, die wissen doch im Vorhinein, wie lang die Werbung ist. Also die können ja einfach sagen, okay, das dauert jetzt acht Minuten lang, bis es pendelt und dann können die acht Minuten Werbung schalten, aber irgendwie haben die es nicht auf die Reihe bekommen manchmal. Das fand ich immer ganz merkwürdig. Aber die Idee ist doch genial, einen Pendel zu starten. Total. Einen Pendel zu starten, was sich ultra lange bewegt und dann weitergeht, wenn die Werbung vorbei ist. Ja. Und ich auch denke, wir machen eine Kettenreaktion sehr lange, wir müssen die Kette nur manchmal unterbrechen, weil wir haben Werbepausen, das ist ein Riesenproblem. Ja, im Grunde ist es immer noch eine Kette, aber ich habe, also, vor allem, da hat sich das ja immer krasser entwickelt irgendwie, bei den ersten Domino Days war es ja dann irgendwie so, okay, es sind kleine Holzsteilchen, okay, sie werden größer, oh mein Gott, es sind VHS-Kassetten, die umfallen, und du sitzt zu Hause und denkst dir, was ist denn bitte hier los, da fallen VHS-Kassetten um, Alter. Zwei, okay, da stehen einfach nur Dominosteine, das ist ein grosses grünes Feld, alles klar. Nur ein grünes Feld. Oh mein Gott, das ergibt ein 1 zu 1 Rennbahnfeld! Und dann denkst du auch so, was ist denn jetzt los? Alter. Ja, drei, es gibt fucking Länderteams und jetzt gibt es auch noch Challenges, es ist nicht mal alles gebaut, die müssen zwischendurch noch Dinge bauen.
Und teilweise hatten die so einen Teil, wo die Blöcke dann so nach unten umgefallen sind. Unter Wasser sogar. Ja, unter Wasser, gegen jede physikalische Gesetze verstossend, so nach unten, als würden die so wegkicken, so ganz seltsam, ganz strange Sachen. Und dann hat jemand das kommentiert. Ja. Da war ein Mensch, der hat den Domino Day kommentiert.
Und ich weiss nicht mehr, wer das war, aber war das ein Sportkommentiert? Ja. Da war ein Mensch, der hat den Domino Day kommentiert. Und ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das war, aber war das ein Sportkommentator oder war das ein Professioneller? Domino-Kommentator. Aber vor allem hat er sich davor eingelesen in die Kunst des Domino-Bounds? Also Sportkommentatoren haben wir oft Hintergrundwissen und wissen, wie oft Leute verletzt waren und bla bla bla und so. Ist es bei Dominosteinen, weiss man dann auch genau so, die Geschichte des Dominosteins? Sport geht ja auch einfach nur von Statistiken. Du hast ja alles schon mal gemessen, du bist mittlerweile immer mehr, deswegen haben die auch immer mehr zu sagen, aber als Dominokommentator, ja meistens fallen nicht alle Steine um, das ist so ein gefährliches Halbwissen. Ich glaube, der hat dann irgendwann die Geschichten erzählt, die die Reise der Steine erzählen sollte, die haben ja immer so Themen gehabt und sowas, dann hatten sie die Afrika-Welt, dann hatten sie die Judenwelt, dann hatten sie den Holocaust-Duell. Ja, ja, dass er ein bisschen abgedriftet hat und man nicht stellt. Da ist natürlich blöd, wenn verschiedene Länderteams dann halt daran arbeiten. Und die Deutschen haben schon wieder auch... Oh nein, schon wieder, ach Gott. Die haben es wieder getan. Aber es war echt ein geiles Event. Und ich habe aber auch nie geglaubt, die Zahl, die dann am Ende von Linda Demol eingeblendet wurde, ne ne ne ne ne, random, random, aber es ist echt zu befriedigend, so eine Kettenreaktion, einfach zu gucken, wie sich also es ist alles schon gesett, es ist alles schon set, es kann, du weisst alles, wie es passieren wird, und du musst nur noch gucken, ob es funktioniert oder nicht. Blanker Payoff, da ist alles schon so viel reingeflossen und alles, was du guckst, ist Pay-off, Pay-off, Pay-off, gibt mir die Scheisse. Es ist ein Film zu gucken. Da haben viele Leute dafür gearbeitet, viel reingesteckt und dann kriegt man einfach den Pay-off die ganze Zeit. Habt ihr das als Kinder auch gemacht, so Dominik Steine gebaut? Ich weiss, ein Freund für mich, hätte wahnsinnig viele und dann haben wir auch immer die ganzen Treppen runter und so und dann ist halt ständig die Katze da durchgelaufen und hat die alle umgeschmissen und ich hab wirklich eine Wut auf diese Katze gehabt, weil wir immer aufgebaut und die Katze halt immer so, als würde sie es wissen, läuft er so durch mit ihrem zotteligen Fell und steigt drüber, steigt drüber, dann schiebt sie nochmal eine Kurve und steigt nochmal und oh ne, ich hab ja vier Beine, ups, hab ich kurz vergessen und zack und alle umgeschmissen, einfach diese scheiss Katze die ganze Zeit. Ja, das hat mein Vater gemacht. Das war ein großes Problem. Das fand ich wirklich geil. Ich habe auch sehr viel gebaut immer, so Dominosteine. Ich hatte auch so Looping und so. Es gab so Dominobaukästen. Ich hatte sehr viele Zauberkästen und Dominobaukästen. Eine Menge Kästen generell. Ich liebe Kästen. Ich liebe auch ihre Kästen. Also das war, meine Kindheit war ganz thematisiert immer. Zauberkasten war auch ein Riesending bei mir. Nee, bei mir überhaupt nicht. Nee, also auch bei Familienfesten habe ich oft einfach das gezaubert. Ja? Ja, mega unangenehm. Ich habe nie gezaubert. Ich habe auch nicht gezaubert. Das waren Tricks gewesen. Ja, ich fand das als Kind schon immer unangenehm Zauberer. Ich war immer schon so... Du warst mir als Kind schon moralisch immer voraus. Ich dachte mir so, fuck it, ey. Und das waren echt coole Tricks eigentlich, auch mit so richtig coolen, präparierten Gegenständen, wo man dann nicht viel machen musste. Und es sah auch bestimmt nicht so wie ihr Gelenk aus und das hat man bestimmt sofort gesehen, dass er noch Tuch aus meinem Daumen rausguckt und so. Du bist leider keine hübsche Assistentin, da hast ja immer deinen Hund genommen, dann irgendwie so einen BH angezogen, so ein Bikini und dann einfach mal so, so meine Assistentin legt sich jetzt in den Kasten. Wuh! Pst, pst, pst. Du bist beim Sägen und der Hund läuft raus. Nein, Jerry, Kindheit ist jetzt vorbei. Genauso wie diese Podcast-UFO-Folge. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart, Podcast Ufo Express, wir werden wahnsinnig viel rausschneiden, ansonsten wünschen wir euch einen schönen Tag, viel Spaß. Was kommt als nächstes in der Spotify-Playlist? Ich wollte einen coolen Song entdeckt, hört mal I Just Don't Know What To Do With Myself von den Wright Stripes. Alles klar, das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht, können wir eigentlich jedes Mal so eine kleine Musikempfehlung machen, weil auf Spotify ist das ja auch realistisch umsetzbar.
Wir können auch eine Playlist machen. Warum denn nicht?
Finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht, die Podcasts suchen Playlist.
Warum ist das echt für jeden was dabei? Naja, eigentlich nur für Leute, die Elektro hören und Musicals.
Na ja, Musicals, ja. Na ja, gut, ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine schöne Woche, vielen Dank, Stefan.
Ciao, mach's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, wir heben ab, mach's gut.